To be a Getty is an extraordinary thing
My grandfather wasn't just the richest man in the world
He was the richest man in the history of the world
We look like you, but we're not like you
It's like we're from another planet
Where the force of gravity is so strong it bends the light
Offends people, too
Mr Getty, your grandson
Miss Getty, we have your son
Is this some kind of joke?
17 million dollars to release him
I don't have any money
Get it from your father-in-law. He has all the money in the world
Mr. Getty is unavailable. I'm sorry Miss Getty
I work for Mr. Getty
I'll help you find your son.
I'm not a real Getty. I just married one. I'm fighting an empire. You need to pay the ransom
They will do things to Paul that cannot be undone for any amount of money
I ask as a mother to set my boy free.
We have to show we're willing to walk away.
I can't walk away
Mr.Getty,  how much would you pay to release your grandson, if not 17 million dollars?
Nothing.